2050 plus aucune artificialisation nette
des sols en France c'est l'objectif qui
s'est fixé par la loi climat et
résilience alors pour s'y tenir la
métropole bléoise a décidé de racheter
et de réhabiliter une friche
industrielle celle de l'ancien site
abandonné de l'AFPA l'Agence nationale
de Formation Professionnelle des Adultes
50 000 m² idéalement situés au cœur du
parc d'activités Blois Nord Villebarou
un projet de près de 3 millions d'euros
co-financés par l'État et agglopolis
explication avec Hélène chapelet
la vie s'est arrêtée ici il y a deux ans
les apprentis maçons ont arrêté de
monter des murs et les tailleurs de
pierre de façonner le tuffeau l'ancien
site de l'AFPA de Blois est aujourd'hui
une friche à ciel ouvert c'est 5
hectares de bâtiments construits dans
les années 70 et propriétés de l'État
viennent d'être rachetés par agglopolis
coût de l'opération un million 500.000
euros
5 hectares très bien placés dans un
environnement favorable à 5 minutes de
l'autoroute à 10 minutes du centre-ville
10 minutes de la gare c'est un atout
majeur pour l'industrialisation de
l'agglomération de Blois mais avant cela
il va falloir dépolluer le site et
démolir une vingtaine de bâtiments plus
aux normes actuelles un budget
prévisionnel qui avoisine les 3 millions
d'euros un exemple concret de ce vers
quoi il faut tendre afin de ne plus
grappiller de terres agricoles pour
installer de nouvelles entreprises il
s'agit d'ailleurs de l'un des objectifs
de la loi climat et résilience ralentir
l'artificialisation des sols
reconstruire la ville sur la ville un
coup qui est légèrement supérieur à
celui de 7 ans il est plus cher parce
qu'il faut évidemment déconstruire
dépolluer puis reconstruire dans cet
esprit en fait l'état dans le cas du
plan de relance accompagne et
accompagnera au cas d'espèces aussi
l'agglomération avec une aide qu'on
appelle fond friche de d'un million et
demi aussi d'euros reste encore à
trouver le ou les bons porteurs de
projets pour faire revivre le site et
créer des emplois la réhabilitation des
lieux devrait déjà prendre quelques
années